>>David: One of the
biggest challenges
that schools everywhere face
is engaging their students
in the education process.
Making school relevant.
Making school matter to the
kids and their families.
We're always looking for a school
that's nailed that challenge.
In this month's, "Schools
that Work," installment,
we go to the Ariel Community
Academy on the Southside of Chicago.
Where with a student population
of modest means, they've seized
on the vehicle of financial
literacy to engage the students
and engage their families,
teaching kids about money.
Teaching them about family economy.
Teaching them about the critical
decision-making that's required
to secure your future, secure
the future of your family.
And to break the cycle of poverty.
The results at Ariel
have been impressive,
97 percent of the students are
graduating from high school;
65 percent are matriculating
into college.
We hope this installment of "Schools
that Work" will be an inspiration
to you, and help you think about
the kinds of changes you can make
to better engage your students.
>>Lennette: Critical thinking
is what every school teaches,
or hopes to teach,
or attempts to teach.
But the thinking is not just enough.
You've got to have action.
And I think financial literacy
is the best venue for that,
because what's more
global than money?
>>Regina: This is a Title 1
school, so we have lots of kids
who are living at or
below the poverty line.
These are average kids who have
the absolute ability to learn
and to understand finance and
economics, because it's couched
in a way that relates to their
everyday life and relates
to decisions that they
are actually making,
or will have to make in the future.
>>Lennette: Financial literacy
is a body of knowledge.
Investing or entrepreneurship
are the subjects.
>>Regina: So we have four main
components of the curriculum.
First grade is personal finance.
Second grade is a combination of
economics and personal finance,
and third grade is
about monetary policy
and what money is and
how does money work.
Well, starting in fourth
grade, it's a lot more fluid.
We want teachers to be
able to pick and choose.
And so instead of teaching
specifically to the test,
we strive to make everything
relevant.
Ariel students typically score much
better in math and better in reading.
>>Judith: The curriculum
needs to be deep.
It needs to be encompassing.
The point of student success
is for students to understand
that with every single classroom
that they participate in,
it is directly connected
to their own life goals.
>>Regina: So our investments
class today, we're going to talk
about spending our money.
What did we do last
investments class?
Who can think back and remember?
what were we spending our money on?
What were we doing?
>>Student: Carnival things.
>>Regina: Yeah, things
at the carnival!
>>Regina: The kids
really respond well
to seeing other children making
decisions in literature that we read.
So either watching a video or
reading a book is a great way
to get them invested.
>>Regina: Listen to
this story carefully.
Let's think, is this
about planned spending?
Someone thought about it carefully?
Or is this about unplanned spending?
They just saw it and they bought it.
"Penny ran to her room to get
some money from her savings bank."
When she put money in that
bank, what is that called?
When she was saving up all her money,
she put the money into the bank?
Shanard?
>>Shanard: Deposit.
>>Regina: Yeah, she was
depositing her money.
"Mom was going to get paper towels,
plant food and a book about flowers
for Miss Kim's birthday present.
Penny added a notebook
to mom's shopping list."
A.J., Penny's mom made a shopping
list just like your parents did.
>>Regina: This is super
important for all children.
It's very important for
the kids that we teach.
Low-income children
have fewer chances.
they already have the
deck stacked against them.
And oftentimes, they are not the
ones who are getting the opportunity
to network, to meet people, and
to take charge of their lives,
so that they can graduate high
school and either find a job
or go on to higher education.
>>Regina: These kids are on a track
to go to excellent high schools,
and to be accepted into college.
And we give them the tools,
and hopefully they take that,
feel inspired, and plan their life
the way that they want to live.
>>Lennette: What we really want kids
to get, to believe in themselves,
to know, "I can do this."
And that, "Yes, I'm going
to think critically.
I'm going to come up
with a good game plan."
You know, it's not just
thinking, you have to do it.
You have to be active.